because it's amazing that palestinians
in israel is meet but in order to
actually try and do something very
significant
with the future of this region maybe
let's try
other methods
[Music]
thank you for joining me on 20 minute
leaders how are you i'm great how are
you michael
fantastic so you're calling me from bear
sheva next to ben gurion university
and while you're while you're finishing
your your undergraduate degree
it doesn't do justice that title to what
you're actually been doing in israel
with tech to peace and dealing with one
of the most extraordinary conflicts in
history
actually a 5 000 year conflict and
making it very relevant to 2020 bringing
technology
and peace into the same equation and i'm
very excited to spend the next 20
minutes or so talking to you about this
conflict but but specifically in the
context of
how can we leverage technology and
commonalities and similarities
to bridge some deeper rooted conflict so
tomer uh take us away tell me a little
bit about yourself and what is tech to
peace
so basically my name is cohen i'm
originally from jerusalem
um so i'm 27 years old
actually about to finish my bachelor
degree in geography and political
science nothing to do with technology so
far
even though in the army i served as a
fighter in a special unit
he would actually he combines between
itec
technology and actually commental so it
was very
it was the the first very strong moment
of the
of the idk in my life in general
in in my first year in my bachelor
degree i actually established
with two other a founders lecture piece
of peace basically what we basically do
is to connect between young
adults from palestine in israel between
ages
20 to 26 by two things the first thing
basically is about learning technology
like if it's programming or mobile out
development
or ai for programmers and etc
every participant for two weeks a long
seminar actually
dedicated a lot of the time to study
this subject and actually to build
its airplane or his own project
in addition to very intensive and very
unique dialogue workshops but actually
my partner is abil
which is from east jerusalem and uri
from haifa
actually doing there they speak about
everything about
very personal experiences about the
history like nakba
and the yamato independence day and all
those issues in two week long seminar
and actually because what we're trying
to do
is to build new partnerships new
friendships and partnerships
that can go for the long term amazing so
just a little bit of context because a
lot of the viewers are from
you know from california not everybody
is aware of the
of the deepness and the complexity of
this conflict but and
and i won't be able to do justice in the
10-second
brief but it essentially talks about the
middle east conflict the
israeli-palestinian conflict it's much
more than just territory it's more than
just culture it's about history it's
about
deep-rooted beliefs it's about
generations of hatred
that have that have erupted to where we
are today in an
unresolved conflict that basically the
whole world is trying to help or or not
help in one way or another
and so so give me a little bit of what
is this program so it's two weeks where
they come together what have you noticed
and actually i want to go back to how it
started because that's a fascinating
story that you started telling me before
yeah so basically about how it started
and what we basically actually do every
day at detective peace
so basically two years ago i met the two
other co-founders abir
as i said which is from east jerusalem
and ue from haifa originally
and they actually they told me about the
work they actually
was running an organization that's
called the yad viad
some israelis maybe know this
organization but this is another
a informal organization which actually
combined
between palestinian like a connected
palestinians in israel is
a food dialogue just to meet being
friends
and actually make you know the the most
significant connections and they did it
for
almost 10 years and like more than 450
palestinians in israel is actually met
through this program fiat we had
and i once i met more than two years ago
i was asking them
what do you think how can we actually
create
bigger impact like like how can we
actually do something
yeah exactly how can we actually because
it's amazing that passions in israel is
meet
but in order to actually try and do
something very significant
with the future of this region maybe
let's try and other methods
and only he told me that he worked for
many years
he is a product manager in the idek
industry in israel
and i was about just finishing
my role in one of the like high-tech
tuition companies
in israel actually like doing summer
camps of high-tech in israel
and we thought okay let's maybe try and
do something else let's maybe try
to do dialogue seminars like dialogue
camps let's say
with i think in the same time but
actually
the participants will get
the advantage to get better future and
something practical for our life
basically and the reason that we started
with this model basically it's because
of two main challenges that
basically you and the audience should
know about
first of all as you can guess many of
the people who
already go to dialogue camps dialogue
seminars between palestinians and
israelis
those are the same convinced people yeah
yeah like israelis from mainly from tel
aviv
and the palestinians mainly from
ramallah from the west part of ramallah
and some other very specific places but
most of the people that actually go
and meet it's still convinced and so we
thought how can we bring
new people new people from the periphery
of israel from the periphery of
palestine from refugee camps
from like bedouins from the negative how
can we bring
someone from ashdod for me is the lord
other
places that are a bit out from tel aviv
from the center
and then we thought about let's try and
bring them
something that actually we can use
something but all the participants we
get
out of the benefit of it basically
and the second reason that we
established dr peace
the second challenge which you wanted
wanted to tackle basically
it was that in many peace camps and in
many other seminars
he basically many times not always but
many times there is no continuity
right and if the palestinians
in the israelis basically had like a
very significant moments and they became
really good friends probably
once the seminar is over or the camp is
over the palestinians go to their home
the israelis go to bear homes and
there's no continuity there's no is it
possible
is it possible to create continuity in a
matter of
a two-week program basically yes because
we sleep together we eat together
at night they actually share the most
intimidating the most personal stories
with one another we're having fun with
one another
and in those moments of after we finish
the program around nine or ten
pm those are the moments that the
friendship actually created
and this is actually what we're trying
to achieve
besides all the very intensive
at least and this is what we do in the
seminars but
other things that you and the audience
actually should know about f2ps
that once the seminar is over all the
participants become
a automatically alumni of the octopus
and they start the alumni program
which means before the coronavirus
preview like every one or two months
actually meeting with experts if it's
from google for microsoft sometimes from
mit from other places
to in order to give them the additional
value of after the seminar
yeah and sometimes also of course also
dialogue
to to to get in depth into the
issues that actually talked during the
seminars
um and also between the 90 alumni
objectives that we have so far
17 of them actually work on cross-border
startups
together it's just started in a couple
of months ago to work on cross-border
startups
with our amazing partners from boston
it's called
a 50 50 startups it's a new startup
incubator
so it's very exciting wow so and and
then
how many people went through this how
many of these two week programs have you
done so far since the inception of this
so the pilot certainly now took place in
a 2018
in yokan down south in a very isolated
small town
he actually mikhail bitum who is now
in the parliament in the in the israeli
knesset
he actually he was the a mayor of this
small town and he was very advocated in
order to
to to let us do the seminars in his in
his town
he and after the pilot seminar we were
surprised because
no one think that actually what is the
connection between idec
and dialogue but after we serve it
actually it works
if we did other two seminars in the
summer of 2019
and in this upcoming summer we hopefully
gonna do
two or even three seminars and and
that's going to be online i guess right
basically no actually as far as
as far as the situation now there is
very good chance that it will work out
but of course no promises it depends
i keep forgetting because i'm here i'm
here in california and the situation
here is much different than it is uh
back in the middle east so uh so i'm
very happy to hear that but
so tell me a little bit about you so
you've had again it's about 15 people
each
for each two week program fairly fifty
pasceans fifteen israel
so you've had about 90 people go through
this
thing so far tell me a little bit about
what you've noticed
about the the openness that that you're
contributing or
or so you know i'm and i'm especially
interested about the continuation of
what do you see happening after the
program with these participants
so basically we tried
a to find in terms of applicants
before the seminars before we accept the
the participants we're trying to find
people
he was who actually have like kind of a
sense of
he that we could be entrepreneurs it
doesn't have to be about itec
it could be also about social impact
stuff of course it could be also about
a rather than the private sector also
the public
and also to work a in the government
one day if it's about the the
palestinian authority or or
in israel we look to find the people who
actually want to be
leaders one day and
enough open-minded to listen to ideas
and concepts that are really not used to
here
right home if it's in the west bank or
in israel
is so this is what we he tried to find
before the seminars
and after the seminar so it really
depends those are you know there are
like alumni who
really want to open startup so we
actually help them to get inside
a uh like the the partnership with the
accelerator that we have
in yellowstone and those were most
you know more thinking about getting
into the idec we also
nowadays trying to find more solutions
for
also for them with microsoft and cisco
and other companies
um so it really depends about the
situation
sure and now let's go a little bit
higher and broader so this
is now impacting uh you know if a few
dozen of people
few dozens of people per summer how do
you get this to scale so then how do you
get
like the two populations to have
meaningful dialogue and and not just in
small groups
so the the best and the easy thing for
us
is basically to do to create more and
more seminars
like now we do two seminars here
hopefully
because the demand like easier we so far
the application is still open and we got
more than 400 applicants for them
for only 60 sports sports for the summer
it's 90 if we will actually be able to
do in the end three seminars instead of
only two
and the demand is exist so we definitely
look to do more seminars a year and in
more concepts for example
a one of our partners mit um so now we
talk about
actually creating short a one
week long seminar which will focus only
about
the mobile app development and dialogue
nice
and also we talk about like doing
another concept of one week
a long seminar with google google for
startups
with the office in tel aviv of one week
long
seminar which actually focuses about
dialogue and about entrepreneurship
about
actually how to build startups for those
who are actually interested
and then we can also find other
thousands i guess of applicants new
applicants but do not
know he he tried to to be candidates for
tech to peace
because you know to take a vacation of
two week long vacation it's
for many people it's a bit hard mainly
for people who
must work all the year or in the summer
vacation
so right that was my next question at
and end these are everybody
everybody's busy and taking out two
weeks to
to form this dialogue and to be open and
to learn even to learn new things
even if it's disconnected from the
israeli palestinian conflict is is very
demanding
so how do you actually find this this
balance in this win-win situation
where people can balance it with their
jobs and do you think there's room to do
things like this outside of a context of
just you know a two-week seminar but
throughout the year and throughout the
life
so basically basically if i got your
question in
right so definitely
we can scale it much more we can do much
more seminars we can create
new concepts but similar to our concept
basically for example
now we collaborate with mit about
a we're helping a a misty it's
the international department of mit
to basically help them to a implement
detect the peace model in other places
warded and the first location hopefully
going to be south africa
in cape town between refugees and local
youth yeah
so you know for me as as a
as is a jewish guy
for me just you know once it will also
spread in other places around the world
for me it's amazing
example of yeah
besides our region but we hopefully know
in a few years we're going to have
hundreds and then after that a thousands
of alumni
will go through the program so you're
you're definitely seeing this grow
and grow at scale and what do you do you
see yourself continuing to be a part of
this full-time over the years or
or do you see yourself slowly
transitioning out and thinking about
other ventures that you want to do
so it really depends because friday
there are really really really tough
moments like you know
three days before seminar when when we
also do not get sometimes the permits
for the palestinians to enter israel
wow and we don't know if the seminar
actually will will take place as planned
with the same participants
or if it's it's about also now with the
coronavirus
of course as other ngos the budget
they is really suffering out of it so
there are
very very intensive and hard moments
for other year but you know for me as a
co-founder like it's really hard to
to to fall asleep at night but
on the other end when someone a
palestinian or israeli
in the last day of the seminar come to
me
you know with the tear under the eye and
actually say to me
you know this experience actually
changed my life this experience was so
significant for me
so so amazing i never thought that
they're gonna have a palestinian friend
and or palestinian i never thought that
they're gonna have an israeli friend
totally um so those moments
of people and it's up it happens a lot
to the peace because it's very emotional
and very
connecting i'm saying i think to myself
i do not want want to be out of it never
but in the
very early nights that i cannot fall
asleep of course i i'm
thinking about maybe it's too tough to
do something
so so crazy you know because in this
reality it's not something
usual to actually connect between
palestinians and israelis
in our region of course it's something
you know in the united states it's so
sometimes not nowadays of course but in
other
times it's easier to bring people from
different backgrounds in the middle east
with all the a suffer with both
sides that many there's so many victims
of both sides there's so many
suffering yeah it's so much history so
just
bring bringing new people to be friends
with people that they never thought was
going to be friends with
and not for only two weeks long exam you
know it's
for months and and hopefully years after
so
those moments are the most significant
this is why i hope to
continue doing that for a long time yeah
you know torah i think that
it's it's amazing because i think it's
very easy from far away to take for
granted this idea of bringing together
people for dialogue
and you know just peaceful dialogue on
friends with with all the differences
and i think that it's just hard to grasp
this idea that that
in the region where we're at in israel
in the middle east in general it's not
that simple to get
a palestinian an israeli in the same
room it's not simple even logistically
just passing the borders
putting aside all the personal
differences and the and
the the fact that your friends are going
to think you're crazy and your family is
going to disown you potentially it's
it's a problem and i think that
being being this catalyst and fostering
this and allowing tapping is something
that's really remarkable and i
i've always said to my family and
friends that i i i
unfortunately have started losing faith
in in the in
the current system of how we're trying
to solve this and my personal
uh belief is that the only way this will
be solved is if my generation if our
generation can grow up more open-minded
visit the world talk to each other in a
friendly way
start putting aside 5 000 years of
differences but focusing on the next
5000 years
and potentially using technology to help
bridge that gap and the similarities
i think that would be wonderful
unfortunately i can't believe 20 minutes
are almost done
but tomorrow i have to know three words
that best describe you
oh it's it's challenging to choose it
came by quickly
yeah i would try a determined
i'm sometimes too much of the determined
i'm honest like i try to be honest with
people as much as possible
it's also very israeli thing to to
e to be in that way yeah
um i have i have other words
multi-disciplinary
maybe a bit impulsive maybe
so i brought four four different words
it's very israel if you ask for free
give me four that's that's what i did
thank you for the inspiration and and
peace it sounds amazing thank you so
much michael
great everybody bye
you